[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are indeed very careful boys very
careful be careful guys today we are not
careful where we have um
well let's be honest nick has been
opening up like a flower around here
beautiful it only took six months we
enjoy it yeah we gave him so many
[ __ ] chances he finally started open
up so thank god 500 videos later yeah i
still don't know what the [ __ ] you guys
are talking about high five on the
camera 775 videos of nick not really
talking now he opens up
so but no it's honestly awesome but um
we i we were talking a little bit and
we're very curious about how you prepare
for a fight day
because like you know we all i've been
watching ufc since like thousand [ __ ]
what six or something [ __ ] win
karate times yeah i did when it was like
bj and all those guys and and gsp and
you know that's just me sounding cool
yeah you know
million dollar man bam bam bigelow
bigelow dude
wait what do you say what you're here
but yeah how do you how do you prepare
for a filing how many weeks out do you
even start
how do you choose what's day one what's
day one of like i know i'm gonna fight
somebody what's day one when i was
fighting it was a very i was fighting
amateur and it was really like
loosey-goosey so there was a lot of
times where
i would they would say all right there's
a day that everyone's gonna bring their
fighters to a gym
and we're gonna find somebody to fight
you
that's how it goes so it'd be a pool of
other gyms in the community saying hey
we're gonna do some kickboxing fights on
this saturday
everyone pull up we're gonna find
someone who is around my weight and you
guys are gonna fight each other later
this day so a lot of times oh so you
wouldn't even know you wouldn't even
know there was this is like this is like
this is like a prohibition error and
people are just trying to go out to the
statute for work yeah it's like me me
people just trying to yeah it's like
they call them smokers or like
exhibitions or something they would use
all these legal names to just kind of
work around because it's like for you to
be able to fight in california it needs
to be sanctioned by an athletic
commission for it to be a whole [ __ ]
thing is this scarier
uh
in the preparation when you know who
you're gonna fight or when it's just up
and or if it's like a big question mark
you know what's funny for me the younger
i was and the earlier in my fight career
the more i was like not really nervous
at all
life is young and dumb
yeah because and then yeah because at
the time i was like dude yeah i'm gonna
fight bro i'm gonna be [ __ ] i'm so
[ __ ] tough blah blah blah because for
me the reason why i started training in
general is because you know i felt like
i had like a chip on my shoulder i was
like i didn't learn how to fight and i
protect myself i'm gonna get my ass
kicked all the time so i might as well
learn how right so it was more of just
proving myself that like oh i could
[ __ ] fight that's what it eventually
came out to be but when i would go to
these fights it was really scary because
you're like [ __ ] i don't know who i'm
gonna fight
a lot of the times too you would get
intimidated by finding fighting someone
who's like has more experience than you
who's probably like like i remember i
got matched up with a guy who had like
seven fights and he was like actually
pretty [ __ ] good and i didn't know at
the time and i ended up fighting him and
i only had like one fight under my belt
oh [ __ ] and he like he [ __ ] me up in
the first round and i was like god damn
so when you're scheduled for that you're
not sizing up your opponent you don't
know anything about his history my my
teammates purposely didn't tell me wow
because they they don't want you to be
like like low self-esteem dude because
that's me all day i'm low self-esteem
head case nick like negative nick like
that's how i don't tell him i'm like i'm
gonna i'm gonna get my ass kicked man
really yeah that's me all the time a
hundred percent so your coach would be
like all right so who's nick's gonna
fight he's like oh that guy over there
he's like
yeah oh dude the guy's real short don't
worry about that and he was he was he's
a short dude and i was like okay this
would be a good fight and then he
[ __ ] clocked me the first punch he
threw
he closed my eye
and then he the second one he threw my
contact flew out
so i couldn't see i was like [ __ ] and i
was like the first round man we were
fighting someone's [ __ ] backyard bro
and the ring was like
the ring was as big as these tables bro
like there's nowhere to run yeah
kimbo sliced in the show what's going on
it was yeah that's what the vibe was
probably like
right in those days when they say nick
was a knockout artist he was like the
one that gets knocked down bro he's like
i could fall on this side
how do you want me to get knocked out
how can we put you over i'm gonna put
you over that's what i'm here to do that
that's exactly who i was yeah but i i
actually won that fight surprisingly i
thought you won that oh you won it i
thought you said you lost well i got
[ __ ] up in the first round we were
like blind
yeah bro and it was purely off instincts
and i just was like
uh how many rounds was it and then when
did you turn dude it was like it was in
the middle of [ __ ] like august and it
was it was like 110 degrees out we were
the last fight we were like 16 16th
fight
people walk into the car yeah dude
honestly we were waiting so [ __ ] long
to fight so already i just was like i
didn't want to be there and i was like
[ __ ]
and it was it was like the whole time
you're going through this emotional
roller coaster um so by the time you
fight you're just like [ __ ] it like by
the time i fought every single time i
was always like all right dude like
let's just get this [ __ ] over with like
i just want to go home you're not hyping
no more you're here yeah you're not
really not hyped like i was like so
fatigued you're not getting paid [ __ ] i
bet huh dude do you [ __ ] wish you got
paid in that fight though when you're
getting [ __ ] up and a contact flew out
how did you
like how did you turn that around in my
head i was like don't get [ __ ] up in
front of your girl that's what i thought
are your girls there and i remember i
remember having deja vu was she
screaming like oh no i remember like i
got cracked and then i grabbed the dude
and then i remember looking out to the
crowd and i see like tiff and a couple
my buddies like like steve green
embarrassed for you
and i'm just like whoa and then because
usually for me it's like once i got
cracked i'd be like oh [ __ ] we're
fighting you know like this dude is
really trying to so it doesn't turn on
until you get hit for me at least which
is probably a very bad strategy
cause you're too friendly yeah yeah
cause nick had no hype no for real like
that's how it was and then i was like
this guy's trying to [ __ ] kill me and
then like like i didn't [ __ ] know the
pretense right like i said
does that like turn on the animal in you
though is that like what i think for me
it does like for me it did and then you
grabbed his jacket you [ __ ] turn it
around
i don't want trouble and then i don't
want any trouble yeah rubble on the
bronx's ass dude
um but then that was like a kickboxing
fight and then when i did i wasn't in
the middle it was yeah it was an mma
fight but how did you win how did you
win that i just i just [ __ ] kept
punching my stomach and i just was like
i was like i couldn't really see
you you [ __ ] them up with one eye yeah
well it was it was hard because i was
like i just said all right i'm just
gonna try to [ __ ] knock this guy out
and that's all i pretty much did like
there was no strategy it's like because
it's so primal at that time and you're
and it's so fresh these are new skills i
was probably kickboxing i was i started
fighting maybe six months in
wow
i was [ __ ] super fresh and in my head
i was like everybody kicks my [ __ ]
ass in the gym i get beat up by
everybody i don't know how the [ __ ] i'm
gonna win this fight and it's purely
like your back is against the wall and
someone's trying to knock you out and
you're like all right i gotta do
something and they put you up against
the guy that has seven yeah he was like
he was like six and one and my buddy
my buddy had trained with him and was
like yo we didn't want to tell you but
this kid's really [ __ ] good and i was
like oh thanks dude thanks bro yeah
you're awesome but that was for me like
it was a validating moment from them how
did that fight get matched up though
like how do you just from weight
that's purely it and was it a decision
by the judges no dude there's no [ __ ]
judge so how did you win like knockout
like there's like three that like it was
a decision so it was just i
i just outlasted him that was it he
started throwing up in the ring
he threw up in the ring
that's a pretty good decision and the
ring's this big dude he threw up like in
the afternoon as we're raising our hands
he's like he's like throwing up holy
[ __ ] you push the pace do you think
where he was like you kind of yeah well
i think he was i thought he probably
thought he was gonna walk right through
me that's probably what it was
over overconfidence [ __ ] him up yeah
and then i just kept [ __ ] punching my
stomach and then over time he just got
more tired more tired and then it gave
more openings for me as the time went on
but at the time it was just like
the only thing that was going through my
head was like this is just what i do in
the gym so i'm just going to do this
here that guy's name by the way jorge
massa
yeah what are you gonna do about it yeah
after that fight
after that fight did you get the bug
you're like [ __ ] you gotta keep doing
this yeah but it also kind of got me a
little more scared like oh [ __ ] like
this is because i saw after that fight i
had like
like crazy dehydration and at the time i
thought it was a concussion [ __ ] oh my
god because i was like [ __ ] up i
couldn't drive home i was like [ __ ]
wrecked so it was like every time i
would fight i would always feel these
feelings and i was like man what the
[ __ ] is going on like
if this is winning i don't know if i can
handle this [ __ ] right like so that
would always be constantly in the back
of my head
and then once i started transitioning to
mma it started getting a little more
serious there was actual like fight
camps where we would have a eight week
training camp of like all right
this was through the commission so i had
to get blood work i'd go get physicals
from doctors and there was people that
would come and actually sanction these
fights so it was like real like there'd
be walkouts and there'd be weigh-ins and
all this [ __ ] so there would be more
things you have to do before the fight
which is actually more like
anxiety-inducing because the longer that
[ __ ] goes you're just like i just want
to [ __ ] fighter it i don't want to do
none of this
i don't want to have to do stand in my
underwear and pose in front of a guy i
didn't want to do any of that [ __ ] i was
like i just want to compete and that's
it how hard is it to like you know
you're going to fight someone but you
don't gotta do all the [ __ ] press
right so like you have to go okay stand
up you're like yeah well dude at that
level yeah it's super awkward like
one of my first fights right here's some
just backyard going like this
this is so funny okay so i was getting
matched up with this this is my first
mma fight
and
in my head i was like dude i have to
stare down with this guy i don't want to
do that [ __ ] i was like 19. yeah you
know i was like i don't want to like
look at me it's gonna be [ __ ] weird
in my head
this is how i knew i wasn't gonna be a
good fighter i was like i don't when i
would train with new people or spar with
new people i would rather want to be
their friend rather than like [ __ ] them
up in training
big teddy bear yeah like i didn't want
to like [ __ ] you up because i don't want
to fight my friends in the gym because
that's what it takes to like be
competitive and be really good but i
just want to hang out and like crack
dick jokes i don't want to do all that
[ __ ] yeah yeah so i would square off
with these dudes like right before we're
gonna fight and in the picture it looks
like i was like i don't want to look him
in the eye so i'm sure he'll look down
you're looking at his dick it looks like
i'm looking at his [ __ ] dick and this
dude had a little chubber too so it
looks like i'm just he's looking at me
in the eyes and i'm like this
looking right at this [ __ ] dick dude
well it that's because back then it was
winter [ __ ] the loser
and i [ __ ] the losers that's when his
ak was dick nunn yeah
no but in that fight it was my first mma
fight i was like really nervous because
at the time i had a lot of insecurities
about like my overall game and i was
like i don't know if i'll be able to
handle this [ __ ] you're 19. i was like
19 probably like 19 or 20 at this time
how many years of training and was this
now this is probably like three years
but in my head but in my head i'm like
i'm [ __ ] terrible like i should not
be fighting like this is constantly
playing in the back of my head why do
you keep signing up for these fights
because i don't know
do people push you or you you're the one
that's it's people pushing me like oh i
think you should fight now i'm like my
coach savant was like i think you're
ready to do an mma fight and then my
head i was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me i was like i don't feel ready at all
for any of this [ __ ] but there was still
an ultimate like desire for you to find
yourself in there when you're waking up
working out you're doing yeah we're
doing the training camp we're training
hard you're doing all you're doing i had
to lose like 15 pounds in like a week
and a half which was [ __ ] terrible
wait you've been training since high
school since like after high school so
like when i was like 17 i started
starting oh [ __ ] and then from there
like what was the moment when someone
was like yo you should actually compete
instead of just like the rest of us that
just train at the gym it was just based
off the coaches right like
the fact that they even put me in fights
in general i was like really
all right you think i'm ready okay [ __ ]
it and at the time i was like this is a
goal of mine so obviously i'm gonna do
whatever it takes to be able to to
achieve that goal but when i when i
started getting in these fights like
dude i don't want to do any of that [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] freaking out all the time
i was like scared and even after i would
like the my first mma fight i won like i
didn't really feel like i was like that
was it
because it happened so quick you the
build up on everything is just
takes [ __ ] all day quick guys in like
a habit and in the first round like you
got to do the press you got to do all
this [ __ ] there's all this anxiety and
then when you actually get to the fight
you're like three minutes in the first
round it's over two minutes in my first
mma fight it finished and you won
because you won yeah but then even
morning
but even the way it happened was very
like underwhelming in my head i was like
i thought that was an early stoppage i
don't think the ref pulled me off a
little too soon like i bet like in my
like that's just how it's not good
enough nick in his head 100
do you relate to when uh you know mike
tyson like they asked him like how come
you went crazy back then he goes man
he's just training for like 16 weeks you
become this machine of war and then you
you just kill the guy in the first round
so when i'm i'm not done with that yeah
yeah and then he goes like i have to go
to the gas station and beat up people
because i've been training yeah like
he's just so [ __ ] hyped for like 16
weeks and that's when i realized that i
don't relate to that where i was like
i'm not a pilot
and that's when i quit yeah honestly
like it's it's like little [ __ ] like
that and it wasn't
and then like i had a good success in my
fights like i would i won like three
fights up until this point and the whole
time i'm telling myself you're gonna
[ __ ] lose why are you even doing this
[ __ ] this is crazy blah blah and then
the final mma fight that i had i
actually lost and going kind of back to
that topic that we talked about that's
where i learned the most that's where i
really felt like this is where the real
growth
and that's the birth of the knockout
artist yeah that's when i was like i'm
gonna get ko'd in everything every time
what was it about the the loss that like
because i went in there so confident
i thought i had i had checked all the
boxes i thought i did everything i
needed to do and then i lost by just
getting held down by this guy who just
didn't make weight you know like i i
just got held down for three rounds i
almost beat him in the last round
and then i just was like that fired me
up like i was like oh [ __ ] i need to
train i need my rest yeah like that's
when i was like okay i need to start
doing more jiu jitsu more wrestling and
really dive deep into that and then once
i kind of went down that rabbit hole
that's when i kind of started seeing
like other outlets and more coaching and
understanding the game as a whole rather
than just like i'm a fighter yeah
exactly like looking at it from like a
macro perspective and i feel once i
pulled back a little bit then i started
to have a little bit more fun and love
for the game and coaching and and like
seeking self-improvement rather than
like
just wanting to beat people up in a
weird way like i don't know it's like
it's like a weird explanation it was
less of an outlet and more of a
discipline exactly in a lot of ways and
i think once that happened for me
that's when i started really getting a
lot more from the sport and like
actually training were you the guy that
told me you [ __ ] up a restaurant
worker because they didn't have anybody
to fight that day
and they had a smoker fight and then
they didn't oh no that was my teammate
that was like one of the first they
pulled like a chef or someone to just
fight it was it was that indian
reservation in saboba oh yeah i remember
those and like the king of the cage
it was similar it was called gladiator
challenge oh yeah this is like the same
thing it's super simple yeah and one of
my buddies it was my first
fight that i cornered uh my buddy for
and the guy the day of the fight
the guy he was gonna fight
just didn't show up
nobody showed up and we're like all
right he [ __ ] up a waiter
dude
he's like you're gonna you're gonna
fight 10 minutes you don't have a
fighter
so then they kept asking corner men and
other
like the people in the crowd this is
what they would do over there they would
they would go to the crowd and be like
hey do you want to fight for like 200
bucks
200 bucks dude that's how it would go
down bro and they asked this guy who was
a corner man
and he this guy's fighting in cargo like
shorts
what year is this
this is i remember this this was the
this was the exact day where anderson
silva broke his shin oh
that was wild so it was probably what
like 2014
2016 wow no 2015 ish i think so it
wasn't like that long ago yeah but it
just shows what a like crazy time the
sport was my buddy fought some random
guy and this would happen all the time
like yeah but what did that random guy
win
no he got [ __ ] up i was like i was
like
what a crazy story though they put it in
bitcoin he's a millionaire
there you go
you're fighting a train killer man the
fighting is [ __ ] it's it's really not
for everyone hey what's your thoughts
what's your thoughts about cte because
every time we talk about fighting now
it's it's kind of creeping in the
conversation that's part of the reason
why i stopped fighting for sure oh it's
it's just the brain um trauma brain
trauma from
not just from concussions yeah yeah it's
like i think it's a protein that
develops from brain trauma and it [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up oh really is that it is a
protein they're finding out so much
about cte like unfortunately the death
of athletes and football and yeah yeah
mma even is yeah that's going to be next
yeah for sure yeah because i've seen a
lot of people
like old ogs in the game come train with
us
and people that we used to watch like
coming up in a sport who are legends
and then
they just have really weird behaviors
like in day to day conversation with and
like just interacting with them and
hanging out with them you're like oh
this is the dark side of fighting
this is the [ __ ] cost that it takes
it because dang when you're getting
punched in a [ __ ] head like that
even in training i mean you're getting
punched constantly dude in training
that's when you get those are all the
injuries i got were in training guys who
were just trying to [ __ ] you up
and you know way bigger guys just not
take care of people in the gym and then
poor gemetic hit and then
then i got like a bunch of concussions
and i started feeling those effects
which is how i mean like for me the last
concussion i got which was really what
like
[ __ ] scared me away from all of this
[ __ ]
was like i got
i didn't even get knocked out or
anything i just got hit in the back and
head and i was just sparring with a
couple of dudes and they were going
really hard and at the time i was
probably like 140 pounds and the guys
were like 240 220.
dude and the the drill was hey we're
going real light like pitter patter boom
boom boom i know where to just [ __ ]
crack you oh and his name is david so
yeah
but honestly that's how it will kind of
go like [ __ ] like that where incidental
contact where you weren't trying to do
that but then things escalate and all of
a sudden we're [ __ ] fighting in the
gym dude you know
we're full on like dude you crack me i'm
gonna [ __ ] try to knock your ass out
too let's go probably not the smartest
thing to do you know and that's why you
sometimes you need good coaches to be
able to regulate that turn it down yeah
and to and to make sure people stay on
pace but
after those like i remember later that
night i finished training i felt fine
and then at dinner like i started
getting the concussion effects and like
lights are really bright and i was
feeling nauseous
went home threw up a bunch oh [ __ ] and
then massive [ __ ] headache and then
um just feeling like kind of really
delirious really scared too because
you're like [ __ ] and at the time it was
probably like the fourth one i had
so i was really freaking out and i
already had thoughts of like [ __ ] what
am i even doing and then once your
family sees you that way that's another
[ __ ] like guilt trip
so you're a coach now so how does that
emotion or that experience translate
into like how you train your students
because
you know what i mean like
those things happen and you kind of want
to get out but now you're also like
coaching people that might potentially
i'm in my head i'm being the coach for
my students the way i wish i was brought
up in the game just like everyone else
right like just passing on better
methods because only because mma in
combat sports in general is pretty young
yeah so
if you could just bring a little bit of
insight
to the coaching methods and how you
bring up new athletes in the game they
could have that you could service them
pretty well a good example is like
when i started training with nick and
his crew
the culture is so different from all the
karate places and like things that i've
experienced because traditionally it's
always been [ __ ] just tough at the
[ __ ] out like i even visited a full
contact uh karate gym and i got my ribs
broken by bad training because dudes
just kick the [ __ ] out of you yeah
whereas like when you're training with
this dude it's like
they go hard and they're great fighters
but they're also
not trying to win a world title belt
while practicing right and and the the
gym culture isn't a bunch of dudes
trying to kill each other every day and
even the one where me and bart went to
our sensei was pretty old school where
he would just be like hey you go fight
this guy he goes but this guy he's like
way [ __ ] bigger and crazy and they're
like so i just want to watch it it's fun
yeah like they'll do stupid [ __ ] like
that all day long
did i see him i've seen the video of
bart being the [ __ ] of like a five five
hundred
[ __ ] he was mugging this guy dude and
he got a belt for him
he got promoted for it
unbelievable it's almost like
toughness over science that's what i
don't like and part of it though like
you need that [ __ ]
a lot of times like you could there's
times and places where you just need to
have hard [ __ ] training bro like
there's you can't substitute it because
it gives you a type of grit
that that science doesn't teach you you
get exactly and then there's the time
and place for it but isn't some of this
like
it's being
like kind of too uh
oh man i'm a man and [ __ ] hundred
percent cause like when i was doing
jewelry karate
you turn your head like that and i'm
like oh [ __ ] hold on dude that's me bro
that's what i can beat yeah like i'm
like trying to do forms to music and i'm
like whoa wait oh whoa i turn my head a
little too fast
i gotta pull the flag man i gotta i'm
dizzy i don't know what i'm doing to my
brain i do remember when i was in
taekwondo and you know you're like
[ __ ] 11 years old but you're like a
second-degree black girl for no reason
because you as long as you pay you get
the [ __ ] okay that's pretty baller
though but but i would [ __ ] like kind
of beat people in in my [ __ ] age
range so then my
you know you know what's happening the
the the master
would [ __ ] spar with me but i'll find
a spot with you and kick me once until
my wind was out i'd be crying on the
floor and that would be the end of my
entire day yeah and i'm sorry
why would you do that he's trying to
humble you dude
i'm like 11 years old you're a black
belt with like 17 black stripes
because of 17 weeks paid
and he just kicks the [ __ ] out 17
degrees get more money dude he's just
like hey you still gotta pay more baby
[Music]
foreign